what would happen if we detonated
humanity's
most powerful nuclear weapon at the
deepest point of the ocean
for sure tsunamis hundreds of meters
high would destroy coastal cities
earthquakes would level countries new
volcanoes would bring us nuclear winter
maybe even earth could be ripped apart
or thrown out of orbit
well almost currently
earth's deepest known point is inside
the mariana trench
the mariana trench is a very deep valley
right at the edge of two tectonic plates
that looks like an upside down mountain
it reaches a depth of about 11
kilometers
almost three times deeper than the dark
grave of the titanic
it's one of the last places on earth for
humans to explore
pitch black and under a thousand
atmospheres of pressure
it's a relatively pristine environment
thanks to the absence of humans
a great place for our nuclear test
we'll use the most powerful nuclear bomb
humans have ever
exploded the rds 220 hydrogen bomb
or tsar bomber its explosion was so
massive
that its shock wave traveled around the
earth three times
and its mushroom cloud stretched 56
kilometers into the sky
its shock wave was strong enough to
destroy everything in a thousand square
kilometers
its fireball hot enough to burn the
rubble
bombs like this release such an enormous
amount of energy at once
that they could boil away an entire lake
and if we set off a nuclear bomb in the
mariana trench
that's exactly what happens let's pull
the trigger
in the first few microseconds the
nuclear fuel undergoes its chain
reaction
and explodes with the power of 50
megatons of tnt
a blinding flash of light illuminates
the darkness of the trench for the first
time in history
the heat of the explosion produces a
cavity a flaming bubble of water vapor
radioactive nuclei and the remains of
very unlucky fish
the bubble grows quickly as it vaporizes
the water around it
the pressure of the bubble is immense
plowing outwards as if there's
nothing in the way sending off a shock
wave that will be felt by seismic
stations and
whales around the world and then almost
as fast as it emerges
it stops on the surface of the earth
this fireball bubble would grow to 10
kilometers the second after it's
detonated
as the atmosphere barely puts up a fight
to hold it back
but the pressure at the bottom of the
mariana trench is enormous
with 11 kilometers of water overhead
being in the mariana trench
is like being crushed by a hydraulic
press from every direction
here a second after the detonation our
bubble is about a kilometer across
when oddly enough it starts to shrink
the bubble overextends itself losing
pressure as it expands
until the water turns it back
recompressing it
the tug of war between the fiery death
bubble and water goes back and forth a
few times
the bubble shrinking and growing until
eventually the bubble loses for good
the pressure around it is too great and
turbulent water begins to chop it up
it becomes something like the underwater
equivalent of a mushroom cloud
as it disintegrates into many smaller
hot and radioactive bubbles drifting
upwards
and as our mighty destructive blast
rises to the surface
it does basically nothing just a small
wave
and a bubbling plume of radioactive warm
water in the pacific
no tsunami will wash away japan or
california
although boats and whales in the area
might have a bad time
the radioactive fallout will be diluted
into the pacific after a few days
although a fair amount of radioactive
water and salt makes it to the
atmosphere
where it collects and then rains down
again even if the wind blows the fall
out directly towards the philippines
the worst of it probably happens over
the oceans
but clearly the real danger comes from
our explosion
triggering earthquakes and volcanoes
right
even if we detonated the bomb right in
the trench at the exact point where
tectonic plates touch
probably not the explosion would
vaporize a part of the sea floor
and turn a lot of sand into glass but
most of the energy goes into the water
not seismic waves earthquakes are
already quite common at tectonic plate
boundaries
and earthquakes with as much seismic
energy as our bomb
happen a few times a year without
triggering any sort of apocalypse
but maybe it will affect the earth's
orbit since no mass is taken away or
added to the earth
our orbit is completely unaffected also
there have been well over a thousand
nuclear tests in the last 70 years
and that didn't change our orbit so why
would this time be different
the strongest forces humanity can
unleash are
laughable compared to the forces of
nature the planet is too big
it doesn't care so what happens to us
if we designate a nuclear weapon really
deep in the ocean
pretty much nothing
did you know that every bird in our
videos has an
owner more than 1 000 people have got
their own bird
it helps us explain things clowns around
in the background
or dies a horrible and avoidable death
if you want your own bird too and you
want it to appear in one of our videos
you can get it at patreon.com slash
kotzkazak patreon is one of the main
ways we sustain ourselves
so on top of getting a super nice avatar
you also help us
make more and better videos
[Music]
me